when i
started learning about philosophy um
philo sophia and philo being the
devotion and so fear being
wisdom or love so it's that devotion to
wisdom devotion to love you and i
talked very briefly about andrew yang
and
when he mentioned uh he tweeted during
his run that he thought that
philosophers should be returned to the
white house i
cheered i fell off my charm like we need
the great intellectual minds of our time
the heterodox thinkers
the people who will question the
commonly held beliefs that used to back
in the day
be in the market square and the elders
and the young young
youngsters used to go and seek out and
the politicians seek out their wisdom
and opinion and becoming older is
inevitable but becoming an elder is a
skill
yeah it is a skill and in general
um we are failing to produce adults
that people are trapped in a kind of
permanent
adolescence and the only people
that we can trust to govern in such
complex
and perplexing times are
the few who have figured out how to
navigate these difficult things we need
philosophers
we don't need exclusively philosophers
but we need
at least a commitment to philosophical
rigor to be part of that conversation
well how do we i know we we there's the
articles of unity
and uh we can
all of us help help move that movement
forward
you and i had talked about andrew yang
and the the
the potential free andrew yang hashtag
um because i just think he's a
tremendous
individual with a ton of political
potential
that's unrealized and i don't think it's
going to be realized
with the current dnc and how it's played
out and their choice
uh which seemed to me to be pre-ordained
beforehand and the
the vp peg seems to be at least
to my mind pre-ordained beforehand and
there is i have a fear
that um that eventually at some point
during that first term if
indeed that happens to be the case and
uh
and joe biden wins that he will step
down
and again these are projections and
i have no
know for a fact it's just based on
everything that i've
seen and witnessed there was there was a
really disturbing
dystopia at play where the power mongers
at the top
are purporting to be the ones who are
the champions of the people at the
bottom in fact
they're doing the quite the opposite in
in closed
rooms and in private oh i agree and i
think there's already an agreement
for biden to step down and that the dnc
is
hoping we won't notice what they're up
to which of course is
um an absolutely frightening transition
in the way governance works even as
dysfunctional as it's been this is a new
level of dysfunction
so how is a question and on one level
the answer is so obvious and i think
those of us
if you see as i alluded to before
each candidate has an iron-clad
argument for their election and that is
the unacceptability of the other
and they are both right and
for anybody if you see only one of their
arguments and the other one is in your
blind spot
then you will say oh well the answer to
what we have to do is simply clear
right you will say either we can't allow
biden to drag this
woke insanity into the white house
because that will destroy america
and that's true on the other hand we
cannot
allow donald trump to politicize us
into oblivion both of these things are
un-american and not decent and too
dangerous
to even contemplate so at the point
that you see both sides and not just the
one you understand that each one is
unacceptable and the answer is well
what would we have to do in order to not
elect either of them and the answer is
all you have to do is believe that it's
possible and what makes it possible is a
lot of people believing that it's
possible so
how about we have that conversation of
belief now
we learn that as we've been taught by
2020 so many times already and we're
only halfway through
the impossible is just around the corner
so
if we can just simply talk ourselves
into saying well
the two major parties forced us into
this
they gave us non-viable options which
requires us to ask
what else can we do we have to do
something else and
it is simply it is ours
to take back the white house and from
there
to restore the republic to functionality
we've run off the end of the tape
and it is time i agree
and there is
uh there is an urgency i
talk about the tyranny of the urgent but
um
you know i think about the articles of
unity we lack
we currently lack consensus
even about matters of basic fact
scientific facts scientists
are being cancelled and
losing their
jobs livelihoods i mean i don't need to
tell you of all people about that
and the current tools of our collective
sense making
are seemingly unable to close this gap
and yes this
brink of economic catastrophe that we
have seemingly been teetering on for
quite some time now
um you know we the the
the how how our manufacturing base
and our reliance on um
we could talk about even corporate
america has gone work
hollywood's gone woke and it's like a
work will go broke like
what did we get do we get everything
every
every app every screen i turn on it's
just
everywhere so
how how can we how can we galvanize this
how can
how can more people because the big the
two big voices on either side
have control of the mainstream media and
the
uh the newspapers the broadcasting media
and um it
seems to be about the ratings and the
money the commoditization
of our values well i mean i think you're
you're asking the right question and in
some sense i don't believe that
corporate america has gone woke
i believe it is doing what is expedient
which is to say
it will broadcast the woke message in
order not to be canceled and to
get back to business as quickly as
possible and so
i think people have not understood what
a large fraction of those who claim to
believe this stuff
is actually accounted for by the same
mechanism people solving their own
personal fears addressing them
by espousing beliefs that they don't
hold and then they will convince
themselves that they do hold them so
they don't have to explain to themselves
why they lied but once you realize that
this is a fringe
and really a very tiny fringe that's
bossing around
giant corporations um individuals that
are shaping society
according to something that we have no
idea how many people actually
believe it then the answer is well
people are solving their own problems
and that looks like
them saying what they don't believe out
of cowardice
what does the opposite look like well it
looks like
taking a risk to say what you do believe
in spite of the fact
that uh you may come out behind rather
than ahead for doing so
and i think you know this is a small
example
but you and i both believe that the
two major parties have delivered
outcomes that are so unacceptable that
we have to
uh consider things like the unity 2020
proposal
and we actually take a risk in so saying
by saying that we are actually risking
looking foolish
we are risking being blamed for some
outcome either of which will be terrible
and i think the point is well people who
have preceded us
have given up far more to protect the
nation
this is a small price to pay and it can
be distributed
if more people join the clearer it will
be that actually we do have an
opportunity to do something
outside of the script and
really at some level if you get it you
don't have much of a choice
we have been delivered unacceptable
options the cost will fall
heaviest on uh the young who have longer
to live in its shadow
it will fall heaviest on those who are
oppressed and therefore not in a
position
to protect themselves financially from
what's coming
so everything
that we hold dear
and just a simple fact of compassion for
those who are vulnerable
seems to require us to demand something
different
and it's time for people to stand up
i agree and i hope more
more and more people uh find
their voice and their clarity and join
together and
um you know and and aren't too afraid of
being
told you know well if you if you
if you go down this path then you're
going to elect
this person again um get behind
this person because that's the only well
one of the beautiful things about
america is everyone
gets everyone above a certain age and
meets the requirements gets to vote
so vote for whoever you would want to
vote for
and if you silence p i think this
happened in england with brexit
and i think we saw a large portion of
that in in 2016 with with president
trump
is when you tell half of the population
or nearly half of the population that
they are wrong
and their voice doesn't matter um
that they are all to use the
the terminology recently which i don't
like using but
you know neo-nazis or white supremacists
or they're all just they're all bad
people or they're crazy because they
believe in god or
um that their opinion doesn't matter
they're gonna they're gonna speak their
mind in the ballot box when they when
they pull that little curtain which in
england is usually when you're gonna
pull a little curtain you tick the box
and so it's it's no surprise that
jeremy corbyn lost in england and brexit
was
i know there are many more factors to it
it's obviously not that simple
but um you know we're we're
we're a huge nation of
very diverse people and
we have great strengths and
um i i seriously believe that you know
someone said to me when i think i'd
retweeted you one day
uh recently about the uh lesser evil and
the animation
when someone wrote oh yeah been tried
before being trump and i remember one of
i remember sitting in school my history
teacher telling me about
one of the kings in england was about to
fight a battle and he saw a spider
and the spider kept trying to spin a web
and it kept drip
and this king had fought 13 sieges and
he or something like that and he
couldn't
find a way to win the battle and finally
as he was just mentally exhausted with
trying to find a way to rally his troops
and strategize how we would win this
particular siege in battle
the spider spun the web and that's where
the phrase if at first you don't
succeed try try try again
and just because it may have in a
different formula been tried before
that is the reason
why we must try again and
try in a different way and like you talk
about the ticket rather than the third
party
you know the ticket right now is is free
there is in fact the rewards to but
to purchasing or buying a ticket which
you don't have to because it's free
is you get you get to
have a seat at a new table and
a new conversation that doesn't exclude
either side that's inclusive and where
i'm at
having just you know done a live stream
inviting antifa and the proud boys on
is i want those extremes i think we
should be bringing those extremes of
society all the perceived extremes
together
to have the difficult challenging
conversations to hold that space to
listen with curiosity
and mediate through our differences and
bring those experts
in who who know way better than i
on how to moderate and mediate
through those conversations and if only
if only for the fact that one side feels
like they've been heard
for a few seconds then that's that
behavioral
barometer if you will may have been just
tended and tempered a little and i think
that
it all starts with self and we can keep
you know the wave form if you will the
movement the patterns the frequency the
harmonious nature of how we can
share a little goodness a little
positivity and move from
hateful to grateful and from striving to
thriving
now it makes perfect sense and the fact
is
there's no guarantee but in a moment
where it is obvious it could be obvious
to everyone
that the country is on the verge of
tearing itself apart it seems to me
that our patriotic obligation is unity
and that the only position that will
feel good in the aftermath no matter
what comes
succeed or fail is to have tried
anybody who didn't try in this moment
who couldn't muster enough imagination
to see a different possibility
despite the fact that the major parties
announced that they were unwilling to
lead
anybody who can't figure it out now wow
i mean
i i just i have a hopeless feeling about
what that must be like and i would say
everyone else
it's time to to wake up and get to work
yeah i agree and i think that answers
the why question
and he who has a why can bear any how
so the how gets answered after the the
why i think that was roomy
so you know answer the why um
do not question the why just answer the
why
for why is the answer and if we can find
a way
to come together and
really galvanize uh
what you're doing just even the word
unity i mean come on
let's don't we all want a little more
unity and unification
it just feels good to even think in that
framework at this moment it's it's
liberating to do it
and i must say i i like your formulation
about um
that you should answer the why and the
how will follow that's really how things
work
uh the why motivates the how if you
start with the how
uh you may well uh spin your wheels
yeah it reminds me i think it was simon
sennick i think his name is he did a
great
presentation on business uh and um
how how the why needs to be answered i
think it was before the how and the rest
of it and many companies start from the
out
the concentric circles out it did to the
middle rather than the other way around
and
apple is a great example of that
you know making making a difference we
believe we can make a difference
we believe we can create products that
will change lives and i think
unity 2020 has already started
to shift perspectives and perceptions
in the court and family homes of public
opinion
and as it settles in more and people see
more um spoken word written text
animation uh the signaling um the
virtuous signaling not
not the virtue signaling of what people
are really coming together to do because
it takes a tremendous amount of people
a tremendous amount of effort i don't
know how you're doing it i don't know
how many people are involved if you need
my help in any way i'm happy to help
um i think more people should come
together
uh to help this um to
to try to try to to find the how
once we've answered the why and uh
your conviction is clear and we will
call on you
sooner than you know